we've been talking about technological
automation on the program for a while
the planned replacement of human workers
with robots or machines or artificial
intelligence there's a fast-food chain
called Cali burger never heard of this I
actually was not aware of this fast-food
chain they are in the United States
they're also in other countries they're
in China and Taiwan Sweden and Qatar
they are going to be setting up robots
in 50 of their stores which we'll be
doing some of the cooking
the robots are manufactured by miso
robotics it's called the kitchen
assistant and it's going to be flipping
burgers okay and it uses the orders that
are fed to it from the order entry
systems to sort of anticipate how many
raw burgers it should be throwing on the
grill and then it also flips the burgers
at the right time and the idea is it's
all programmed to get the burgers cooked
at exactly the time that they need to be
available now it's not going to replace
humans altogether you'll still need
humans to then grab the bun and add
other toppings and package it for
service to customers but it's pretty
obvious that it's not going to be long
before the machines can do that as well
right I mean when you see this
technology it's not that much further
that it has to go to be able to add the
toppings or throw it in a burger box the
CEO of miso robotics is very upfront
that this is going to eliminate jobs
David's Ito saying quote tasting food
and creating recipes will always be the
purview of a chef and restaurants are
gathering places where we go to interact
with each other humans will always play
a very critical role in the hospitality
side of the business given the social
aspects of food we just don't know what
the new roles will be yet in the
industry I actually kind of think this
is a pointless and unnecessary robot in
the sense that instead of flipping
burgers you can redesign the kitchen to
just grill the burger from both sides at
the same time and then you can cut down
on labor and on cooking time not that I
actually go to these places but that
sounds to me like it would be simpler
than creating a burger flipping robot
but I guess this is kind of an
in-between right this is a robot that
can work in an existing kitchen
design for humans eventually you're
gonna be able to redesign the entire
kitchen to not even need people it is
pretty cool how it can work with the
other humans and the restaurant and get
out of the way if it needs to but I
think you're right we're probably
heading towards some standalone device
where the robot can just cook the burger
inwardly and not have to move it around
and then flip it and then put it on
another stage where you have to add the
bun and everything else yeah this is
like an intermediate paradigm where we
are still thinking of technology that
can work within the context of humans
but the eventual long term is clearly
that the human will be obsolete here and
actually this is sort of an argument for
I mean it's obviously an argument for
basic income and we've been talking
about that it's also an argument for a
$15 minimum wage at fast-food
restaurants right I mean most of the
employees will be gone you can
definitely afford to pay the few that
are left the $15 an hour and it's a
silly little micro example but this is
coming there are still these automation
skeptics around there saying oh people
are exaggerating the coming destruction
of jobs by technology I'm not so sure
it's not really gonna happen you might
need heavy-handed taxation which Bill
Gates has actually suggested to really
avoid the takeover of a lot of these
jobs by technology and you would also
need people to put their feet down and
say I will not go to a restaurant that
does this I don't go to any restaurants
that have this because I haven't gone to
fast-food restaurants for 15 years would
you now avoid let's say Kali burger had
a vegan burger or something that's gonna
say be a vegan burger right would you
choose not to go to Kali burger because
they are replacing employees with
machines not necessarily I mean it's not
as if I avoid self-checkouts at the
grocery store because I understand that
that's taking away jobs from people who
would otherwise be working in the
cashier I have friends who do they won't
go to the grocery stores that have the
self checkouts because they say I
support cashier jobs I think it's sort
of it's not moot but it's a losing
battle I mean it's very clear you if you
go to a grocery store later on in the
evening that has the self checkouts
you've got one cashier and five self
checkouts that are open and I just don't
think it's really gonna make a
difference long term really if you want
to stop this you probably have to do
what Bill Gates
suggesting which is tax robot labor the
way that you would an actual employee or
even higher and I don't know what the
future of that policy is the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad